let's jump back to gender and let's go
over to what was once my home state i'm
embarrassed to say it was here's
governor kathy seaward new yorkers you
can now choose x as your gender marker
on your driver's license every person
deserves to have an identity document
that reflects who they are this is a
historic change in our fight to make new
york a more inclusive and just state for
all what a ridiculous buffoon kathy is
she is just horrible remember nobody
voted for her this is a woman who came
in after they got rid of andrew cuomo x
is not a gender okay usually you put x
on things because i'm not that am xing
it out i'm crossing it out or x
it just means nothing right x is not a
gender so on your driver's license you
could just put x and just because you
put x doesn't mean you're not a man or a
woman you still are a man or a woman
god you people are terrible but there's
more here's new york city this is an
incredible tweet this is from noah
pollock he found this one this is wild
from the new york city subway friend who
lives in manhattan sends pic of this
subway ad courtesy of the new york city
department of health heroin addiction
it's empowering don't be ashamed you are
using be empowered that you are using
safely
this is the nonsense
this is the complete and utter nonsense
that they are now putting on the subway
too the ad in no way condemns people who
are using heroin or makes it seem to
young people perhaps that using heroin
is bad it basically don't be ashamed of
using heroin you know kind of use it
more responsibly be cool about your
heroin usage you know what i mean and
your meth usage and all that stuff you
know let's get you on some opioids too
you want some crack
god these people are horrible so you
will
i don't know what that i don't know
exactly what that was um that was like a
cool guy being like yo you want to buy
some drugs man um
these but so okay so they want to
confuse you about your gender gender
they want to make everyone think
everyone's racist they want you on
heroin
you